large language models like chats GPT are
examples of foundation models large
reusable models that have been trained
on vast amounts of knowledge on the
internet and they're super flexible the
same large language model can analyze
illegal document or write a poem about
my soccer team but what if we want to
improve the performance of pre-trained
llms or large language models to address
a specialized task well until recently
the best way to do that was using a
method
that is known as fine
tuning
now with fine tuning you gather and
label examples of the target task lots
and lots of examples and you fine tune
your model rather than train an entirely
new one from scratch but there's a
simpler far more energy efficient
technique that has emerged in place of
fine tuning and that is known
as prompt
tuning
so what is prompt tuning well prompt
tuning allows a company with limited
data to tailor a massive model to a very
narrow task and there's no need for
Gathering thousands of labeled examples
like we have to do with fine tuning in
prompt tuning the best cues or front-end
prompts are fed to your AI model to give
it task specific context the prompts can
be extra words introduced by human or
more commonly an AI generated number
introduced into the model's embedding
layer to guide the model towards a
desired decision or prediction now if
all this sounds a little bit familiar
using prompts to guide the output of an
llm that's because it most certainly is
that is an example of something else
called prompt
engineering
now prompt engineering is the task of
developing prompts that guide an llm to
perform a specialized tasks honestly it
sounds like a lot of fun I think I'd
quite like to be a prompt engineer one
day so if I want my llm to specialize as
an English to French language translator
I might engineer a prompt to do so so my
prompt might start with let's say
translate and we want to translate
English
to
French
that's the task description of my prompt
then I'm going to add some few short
examples so let's let's add those now so
here's the English word bread into the
French word Pam
that's one that's one shot example let's
add another butter we're gonna turn that
into Burr
and then the next part of my prompt I'm
going to add the word that I wanted to
translate next so cheese
and that's it
now prompts like this written by a human
me Mr wannabe prompt engineer himself
they Prime the model to retrieve the
appropriate response from the llm's vast
memory in this case specifically for
other words in French and the model's
output is its prediction what is this
model gonna output
fromage
that worked we've used prompt
engineering to train a model to perform
a specialized task with just a single
prompt introduced at inference time
without needing the model to be very
trained but
if the task is more complex than this it
may require dozens of these prompts and
so these handcrafted prompts have begun
to be replaced by AI designated prompts
known as
soft
prompts
now soft prompts have been shown to
outperform human engineered prompts
which we can know now as hard prompts
these were hard-coded by a human
this is not good news for my prompt
engineering career because you see
unlike hard prompts AI designed soft
prompts they're used in prompt tuning
and they are unrecognizable to the human
eye each prompt consists of an embedding
or strings of numbers that distill
Knowledge from the larger model
and these soft prompts can be high level
or task specific and act as a substitute
for additional training data and
Incredibly effective in guiding the
model towards the desired output
but do keep in mind that one drawback of
prompt tuning in soft prompts in general
is its lack of interpretability that
means that the AI discovers prompts
optimized for a given task but it often
can't explain why it chose those
embeddings like deep learning models
themselves soft prompts are opaque
all right so let's consider we have here
a pre-trained
model so this might be
a large language model something like
that
okay
now let's consider three options for
tailoring this pre-trained model for
specialization
and I'm going to talk about the three
that we've covered here so first of all
fine tuning
so with fine tuning we take this
pre-trained model and we supplement it
we supplement it specifically with
tunable examples these are the thousands
of examples that I talked about right at
the beginning
once we've done that we can then provide
our input data into the model and it
should now be able to perform our
specialization
so that's fine tuning what about prompt
engineering how is that different well
with prompt engineering we take the
model as it is we haven't tuned it and
then we add in an additional prompt so
we have our input prompt
but we also add into that input prompt
and engineered
prompt which sits in front of it
so we effectively provide two prompts
here for the specialization
that's that's what we did with our
language translator so we provided this
pre-written engineered prompt and then
we provided our input which was cheese
so that's prompt engineering what about
prompt
tuning how is that different well with
prompt tuning again we use the
pre-trained model as it is and we again
provide an input
but we also provide
something in front of that input and
that is the tunable soft
prompt that is generated by the AI
itself and it's the combination of these
two things that allow us to use the
model in a specialized way
prompt tuning is proving to be a game
changer in a variety of areas for
instance in multitask learning where
modelers need to quickly switch between
tasks researchers are finding ways to
create Universal prompts that can be
easily recycled techniques like
multitask prompt tuning allow the model
to be adapted swiftly and for a fraction
of the cost of retraining prompt tuning
is also showing promise in the field of
continual learning where AI models need
to learn new tasks and Concepts without
forgetting the old ones essentially
prompt tuning allows you to adapt your
model to specialized tasks faster than
fine-tuning and prompt engineering
making it easier to find and fix
problems
my career as a prompt engineer might be
over before it started so I guess it's
back to the drawing board or rather back
to the embedding layer because in the AI
World a string of numbers is worth a
thousand words
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like And subscribe thanks for watching